all right anthony
that last play was tremendous right at
the buzzer game-winning shot
in your first conference finals that
you've ever competed in
first walk me through in that place was
there any doubt in your mind who was
taking that last shot no
we ran the play supposed to be for braun
i looked at rondo the whole time
you know people talking about never in
this moment
pressure am i ready for it i want to
take those shots
you know it's part of the legacy i want
those shots i want the big time plays
you know and we don't live with me that
will be shooting
the last you know game-winning shots and
i made it you know that's what this is
what they brought me here for
they made big time plays obviously we
win the mama jerseys
never want to lose in these jerseys
never want to lose at all but that's a
hell of a team they don't keep fighting
they fall all the way to the last shot
you know we know that's what they're
going to do
you know they they had a team that's
proven it this entire playoff series
you know their entire playoff run so you
know hats off to them but
you know we want to come here and do
what we got to do your teammates have
told you for us to win we have to go
through you but there can be different
stars throughout the game for this
lakers team that's how deep you are
lebron came out
had the first 12 points for the team you
hit the game-winning shot what does it
show you about
how special the depth is of this team
man we're a team who who believe in each
other no matter who comes in
you know for javelin dwight to switch
roles to play on jokers you know
for me to get on them you know for guys
to come and make big shots
big plays ac you know um doe
markeif you know all our guys to come in
off the bench and play well for us
you know night in the night out you know
not just tonight but this entire playoff
series in the entire season so
how about this guy when he dunked it and
the whole bench erupted what were you
thinking when he threw it down earlier
he's the goat he did real goat man we
called him goat
he made big time plays for us you know
he always catching the body
but he plays well for us he plays hard
he's scrappy probably the scrappy
the most scrappy scrappiest on our team
and we don't keep fighting
like i say we did nothing special we
took care of home court
quote unquote and now we gotta we got
two more
congrats on the win ad thanks for your
time well
reggie five made three pointers in the
last seven minutes
and the game winner by anthony davis
well it's one thing
to say you want to be in these pressure
moments
it's another to be able to deliver and
when you want the ball and you can
deliver like this
this is what makes your stature grow as
a great player
[Applause]
37 in game one he goes for 31 tonight
anthony davis made two threes his last
one
a game winner and the lakers are up 2-0
in this best of seven series wow what a
finish
lakers up 2-0 you can catch game three
of the western conference finals tuesday
at night eastern on tnt